everyone welcome welcome welcome in to
another spellbinding that's right
spellbinding edition of Market takes
listen I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you're here
with me and I appreciate that I'm your
host Dion rabone reporter at the Wall
Street Journal listen there is a lot
going on right now there's a lot to
explain and I think we could be in store
for a big potentially Market moving week
of data in terms of the information that
we're going to be getting it's going to
be coming at us from all sides but I
have the three most important things to
look for this week I'm going to break
down what they are why they matter and
do a little separation of the signal and
noise for you first off we have this
week's CPI inflation report that is the
big one that I think all eyes in the
market will be on but there are some
other very key pieces of data we'll also
get second we get the nfib small
business optimism survey uh that is out
Tuesday tomorrow you're going to want to
look at that I'll explain why and third
Congress returns to Washington both the
house and the Senate it later this week
so expect to see a lot of headlines
about the debt ceiling I'm going to
explain what that is why it matters what
to really look for in terms of what we
get this week because there's going to
be a lot of information flying at you
I'll break all that down in just a
minute so let's start with the big one
first off this week on Wednesday we get
CPI the Consumer Price Index we'll be
right here on Market takes breaking down
what happens with that what you're going
to want to look for is listen inflation
is still very high still much higher
than the Federal Reserve wants it and
that's shown in the data so I want to
put something up here on your screen
right now just give you an idea of what
we're looking at now we've seen
inflation consistently coming down over
that time period you see it picking up
through 2021 and into 2022 then it hits
9 in June and it's come down every month
since then pretty consistently we are
now at about five percent though that's
still more than double the fed's Target
and still the highest inflation if you
take out this 2021-2022 period still
about the highest we would have seen in
20 years so lower but still not low the
other key piece this is another chart I
want to put up here on your screen right
now and that is the core Consumer Price
Index that's when you take out volatile
food and energy prices what you see
there the index doesn't go up as high it
doesn't reach that nine percent level
but you see it start to pick up and last
month in March or last month we got the
report for March that showed inflation
um on the core side CPI core inflation
rising to 5.6 percent now why does that
matter every I know what you're thinking
food and energy that's gas and food what
I buy at the store what I eat that's
most of what I spend my money on and
that's true for a lot of folks but what
the FED feels like it can control things
that are more interest rate sensitive
are measured here by this CPI core
number and as you see that really has
not been coming back down and in fact it
actually increased in March and so that
tells you that what the fed's doing
isn't having the intended effect so this
chart these two charts really just
illustrating the difference that we are
seeing between the overall CPI Ai and
inflation and the core inflation what
the FED watches and what the FED thinks
of as a predictor or a kind of indicator
of where inflation is headed if that's
correct inflation could be headed back
up and that's why you'll want to watch
the CPI report that we get this
Wednesday also last week if you were
here with us on Market takes on Friday
we talked about the jobs report and we
talked about have that hour average
hourly earnings number picked back up
last month unexpectedly Rose and that
could mean that inflation is starting to
pick back up in the U.S we also have
seen around the world inflation starting
to pick back up you saw central banks in
Norway and in Australia kind of surprise
markets with a rate hike as in raising
rates after they thought both central
banks kind of thought they were done and
then boom had to say okay well
inflation's picking back up again we got
to raise rates you could see something
like that from the fed maybe June maybe
further down the line you're going to
want to watch that report CPI on
Wednesday be with us here on Market
takes 10 a.m Eastern Time next up the
nfib small business optimism report I
want to put up here on your screen a
chart of what we've seen from that
report in recent months now this report
I want to point out a couple things you
see the downward trajectory right pretty
obviously going down we aren't at those
all-time low levels that we hit back in
late 2022 but we are heading that way
the other thing you want to look for is
you see the highest number the highest
reading that we've gotten since the
start of 2022 was 97 right well if you
look back over the history of the survey
49 years almost 50 years the average is
98 and we haven't even had a reading of
98 since the beginning of 2022 we are
well below that and if confidence
continues to move lower well this is
historically bad again you would
normally have about half the readings
above that 98 number half below we have
seen nothing but readings below that 98
number you see nothing but down down
down and Below 98 that's the 49 year
average so we are seeing consistently
declining sentiment uh among businesses
and that chart right there just
illustrating that declining sentiment
and how low sentiment has been for some
time among small businesses 15 straight
months below the 49 year average and
that's really important because listen
small businesses have done all the net
hiring since 2020 since the pandemic all
the hiring has been done by small
businesses and we are starting to see
more small businesses cut jobs and
actually reduce and have to lay off
workers right as they were just starting
to really pick up the pace and hire more
workers we're seeing that Trend reverse
in some of the the jolts data that we've
seen basically the engine of growth for
the U.S economy is starting to stall and
we are seeing that want to put one more
chart up here on your screen that really
kind of shows us what we've seen in
terms of big companies versus small that
green line is the QQQ NASDAQ index
that's the NASDAQ 100 big companies like
meta Amazon alphabet Apple all those
huge Tech names that you hear about
those have returned over 20 percent year
to date now in the middle that red line
that's the S P 500 that's done about
seven percent year-to-date but that blue
line you see that's the Russell 2000
those are those small companies those
companies more tied to the overall
health of the US economy that's
basically been a zero percent return for
investors so far this year so this
illustrating really the big difference
the huge difference between what big
companies are doing how investors are
putting their money into big companies
how they're putting their money into
small companies obviously investors
having a lot more confidence right now
in the bigger companies those big Tech
names and that's what we're seeing so
how could this affect the real economy
because those small businesses we know
are the growth engine small businesses
are showing increased layoffs the latest
jolt survey showed 72 percent of the
increase in layoffs was from companies
with one to nine workers 72 almost
three-fourths
um those companies added had about 185
increase in layoffs that was about 72
percent firms with over 5 000 workers
had a zero increase from February to
March compared to a significant increase
from those smaller companies you were
just seeing a big difference between
what's happening at large companies and
small companies and we're seeing it in
terms of hiring and layoffs
um so this nfib small business optimism
survey will be the first piece of data
that we've seen that tells us what's
happening with small businesses since
this banking crisis and we know small
businesses more reliant on banks than
big ones we also get as a bonus later
today we get the FED senior loan officer
opinion survey that's going to tell us
whether banks are tightening lending
standards or loosening them we are
already recession levels on that
indicator and we will see what the
latest numbers tell us moving on to the
debt ceiling we get the debate can begin
this week the house is returning today
the Senate returns tomorrow really quick
let's step back and talk about what the
debt ceiling is debt ceiling is just a
cap on how much the U.S can borrow we
technically already reached the ceiling
in January of this year 31.4 trillion
dollars we know that this has been
raised pretty consistently it's
generally it had been just sort of a
routine measure
since 1960 Congress has increased the
debt ceiling 60 or 78 times excuse me
most recently in 2021 49 happening on
the Republican president's 29 happening
under democratic presidents uh really
what it is is just hey we got to pay for
all these other things that we already
paid for that we already bought and we
have to pay for them now by borrowing
more money the US doesn't make enough
money anywhere near enough money in
taxes to actually pay for the things
that it spends money on so they have to
borrow money and that's why we've got a
national debt of 31.5 almost trillion
dollars and that's where that comes from
and so that's got to be paid and fed
share Jerome Palace said listen there's
no reason we should even be discussing
this matter but Congress meets this week
and you're probably going to hear a lot
about that so really quick let's take a
look at the Timeline right April 18th
was the most recent thing that happened
that was tax day that showed how much
tax receipts had come in and that's why
fed or I'm sorry treasury secretary
Janet Yellen had said listen we are
going to by June 1st run up against the
ceiling where we aren't going to be able
to pay for certain things she hasn't
said what those certain things are going
to be but the treasury has looked at how
much money is coming in taxes they've
looked at how much money they have how
much borrowing they can do and they've
said by June by June 1st sorry June 1st
we're gonna have to stop paying for some
things and really Congress love about a
week after that to come up with a deal
now here's why this week and the week
after are going to be so important the
house is out of Washington the week of
May 29th through June 5th the Senate is
out for May 22nd to May 29th so if they
don't get anything done before the end
of next week they are going to be out
one branch is going to be out in the
following week the next Branch will be
at and at the end of that week you're
going to already run into that deadline
that's treasury secretary Janet Yellen
says we are going to hit so this week is
going to be big next week it will also
be big you'll hear a lot about that the
treasury market is already showing some
worries if you look at the t-bill market
you're seeing some of those treasury
bills that mature around the time the
debt ceiling comes due those have been
raising and yield which means declining
in price and you're already seeing
investors react to the possibility of
maybe not getting a debt sailing deal
this week will be very important if it
looks like we're not getting a deal you
could see some treasury yields start to
spike that could move the stock market
as well as other markets around the
globe Hey listen that's going to do it
for us here on Market takes thank you so
much for tuning in I know you could have
been anywhere in the world but you were
here with me and I appreciate that I'm
Dion rabone reporter at the Wall Street
Journal will be here Wednesday for I'm
sorry Wednesday 10 a.m Eastern Time to
unpack CPI hope you'll be with us when
we do it again next time